okay this is uh pete peppers
with candy crush sodasagatips.com
and this is a short tutorial about how
chocolate levels work in um candy crush
soda saga
so you can see here by the little
introduction screen was supposed to make
matches
beside the chocolate
to remove it
so this is the first
chocolate level and um
it's the simplest one
see we make a match
and we remove some of the chocolate
now if we're making matches
that touch the chocolate
like this one
then the chocolate doesn't grow
but if you watch
if i make this one up here instead
well it dropped down and hit it anyways
but try it again
if you make one up on the top that
doesn't then another square chocolate
grows
with regular chocolate
um one square will grow each time that
you make a match that doesn't
hit the factor
just like that
but the complete chocolate levels um you
have to get rid of all the chocolate you
can see we have two left here three
moves
and you can shoot them with special
candies like this
model growing here
and
we're going to fail on this one since we
didn't
since i showed you what happens when you
let it grow
we'll just play this one again real
quick to show though
so
like i said the
goal is to get rid of them all so
this is how you do it
you won't always be able to make matches
that hit the chocolate
but when you can
especially on these simpler ones you're
going to want to so that you can
keep it from growing
and in general tips are you know a match
that'll hit as many pieces of chocolate
at one time will be better than other
matches
you can see how the um
the wrap candy will explode several
pieces at once
and there you go that's a
that's an easy chocolate level
all the candy's gone you get the check
mark and the logo is over
now chocolate levels are probably the
hardest
level type
it definitely was in the um
the beginning part of the game
and they get pretty complicated as you
go along
like this is a tougher one you can see
that
you know all the chocolate isn't
immediately um
in the beginning you can't make any
matches
really that damage it
and you get all these blockers to work
around to
get to where you can
open the board up
so that's just another example um on
this level you know you're going to want
to get to these special candies and
get rid of all these cupcake type
blockers so that you can get them all
and
on this particular kind where there's
less chocolate and it's more spread out
the fish will be good because if you if
you crack a few activated fish right
here he'll go and get one of these
pieces that's a little bit harder to
reach
on other kinds of
chocolate levels
like um level 75 for example where it's
a bunch of chocolate that's constantly
growing
fish won't be as helpful there
what you'll want to do there is maybe if
you make fish combine them with other
special candies so that you can take out
a lot of chocolate at one time
all right so i'll just show you there's
one more
like i said chocolate levels are
probably the hardest
and this is these are regular chocolate
levels
it actually even gets worse whenever you
um
get into the higher levels
okay so this is level 121 and this is
white
chocolate and this is a lot worse than
the regular chocolate
white chocolate comes in two layers
and
it grows twice as fast as regular
chocolate
so like this part without the um
the logo on top
would be similar to
the regular chocolate colored chocolate
except for
even if you had all these on the board
they would you they would grow by two
each time you made a match that hit them
instead of just buy one like the regular
chocolate
but otherwise it works the same um
you blast through it whenever you hit
the double layered
chocolate you um
you know you get the uh
it goes down to the single layer
and you just
work your way down
i just want to make a match really quick
that doesn't hit any chocolate okay so
you can see right there
a layer was added to this one and a new
piece grew there here's another one
and you can see
two pieces grow at the same time so
white chocolate is
really difficult to play
when i first got to the white chocolate
levels i thought
at that time that nothing could be
harder than the chocolate levels and
found out that this actually is
so
if you have any questions about
chocolate it's a pretty straightforward
level
type
leave a comment below
make sure
you like the video if you found it
helpful
and
make sure you visit our site
canyoncressotasagatips.com
for any questions you have about the
game
thanks